misguided people on YouTube the likes of
Ali da the likes
of these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them Subhan
Allah that we drink along water and many
other things many fruits to pick from
many foods to eat from Subhan Allah what
about the people who are starving in
Gaza all around the world who do not
have food to eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down our throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for the food
project guys and they are a 100%
donation policy charity I know the
brothers who run the charity and I have
full trust in them that the prophet P
said the Muslim is not the one when his
neighbor is hungry his stomach is
full brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
so this video is I wouldn't say a
response video but a video that I'm
going to react to which is which was
directed to myself um uh pertaining to
being uh labeled as a wahhabi uh as a
jahil misguided people on YouTube the
likes of Ali da the likes of and to be
honest I wasn't really offended by being
called a j or a wahabi I'm being called
you know many things I've been called a
mush a spy a many things are being
called to me so I don't really that
doesn't really bother me but I was
actually more offended that I was put in
the same category of uh another brother
that that really actually got to me more
uh now obviously this message is to
Rashid I'm calling M because um he's
senior knowledge and he's senior in age
and I have respect for him um having
respect for him does not mean that um
you know like um I have some kind of
fear against him or you know for that
matter but but just something that I
wanted to point out because as you guys
know for the past I would say seven six
seven months uh since uh the October
attacks that happened Subhan Allah
what's going on in Palestine to our
brothers and sisters I thought it is
very important and Paramount for us to
talk about this why because I've seen a
pattern um not that I've been following
sh Rashid but I've seen this pattern
where he's continuously um putting
people on the spot I don't know if this
is all like arranged prior is it
happened on the spot I don't know but
for some OD reason there's always a
cameraman so one thing happened that I
saw of a video of him in a
wedding you want to debate on what
you've been coming out with a lot of
rubbish videos about me so why don't you
debate me there's no rubbish videos but
if you want to debate let's debate
now what
are whatever issues are brought up
against you they're in the public domain
this is a wedding of just imagine there
is a wedding you are invited to this
wedding and in this wedding you choose
to have a credle discussion with
somebody and you put the camera on him
and now you're trying to stick it on him
and I thought to myself it seemed a
little bit odd it seemed a bit like why
would one find the need to do that in a
wedding out of everywhere wedding is
somewhere you come you celebrate you you
congratulate you eat food you have a
good time but to use that opportunity
and have a dedicated cameraman there
who's recording and the audio seemed
quite good so it seems like you know
everything was organized you know
premeditated I found that I found that a
bit strange but I thought let it be but
one thing that um another thing that
happened that kind of bothered me was
when our brother Muhammad hijab um
obviously which is from our religion we
know from the evidence from H the
prophet peace be upon him when he came
together with the mus about a man who
was oppressed we know inah Allah
says that come together towards
righteousness and if you guys remember a
attack happen
in a Shia I don't know RAF mosque um
where a individual tried to run over
group of Shia Muslims and we went there
with myself mmed and ab safia and we
went there to address it and say this
was wrong because the person who's
attacking them did not say this is a
Shia or this is a Muslim this is Sunni
this is this or this is that he was
attacking Muslims we went and spoke out
against it so mamed was obviously
invited to an event and rightly so and
we fully support him not that he needs
our support or not but it is pertaining
to our brothers and sisters in Palestine
and what's going on there I was Gob
smacked like I was shocked and to see
someone like yourself of your you know
your age your knowledge um the way you
conduct yourself to sticking on Muhammad
hijab on the spot on stage position in
the past but he doesn't have any
positions yes
and and if he has any association with
any
he corrects them that's the case yes he
corrects those guys that say things that
they should not say in public we ask
Allah toite us on the upon the truth us
on and try to you I don't know what you
did maybe you had to prove a point to
maybe your your audence I don't know but
to put him in such an uncomfortable
position and say oh you know by the way
hijab is not a wahhabi oh by the way
hijab is a Sufi or by the way hij and I
was thinking to myself Subhan Allah this
is an event pertaining not to ourselves
because it's a selfish act to do by
going there and talking about something
a credal issue that we have our position
is very clear yes uh I'm I follow I's
view I am proud of it w I am outright
proud of it I have yeah I'm not sugar
quoting it fully fully follow i t now
the point is this that you go and stick
it on him on stage and W let me be
honest I know Muhammad he's my brother I
know him very closely aldah yeah he can
lose his call he can sometimes have a
temperament but I was amazed and
astonished that he bit his tongue
because he could have come and say hold
on a second you know when I was looking
at his facial I was looking at hijab
face when you was making these remarks
yeah the fact that he did something that
I would have expected you to do amazed
me why because he understood that the
objective of the event was there for our
brothers and sisters in palestin that
are being massacred you know that I know
that so he bit his tongue so much so at
the cost of many people who were coming
and saying oh is hijab now this
irrelevant because the cause was greater
than hijabs honor or his reputation it
was about our brothers and sisters in
Palestine so I admire that in him and
told this to his face now the point is
the following why is there a reoccurring
pattern because now they are about to
attack Rafa or they are attacking Rafa
we have non-muslims who are on the
streets protesting in University
campuses all around the world and then
we have yourself who is senior knowledge
senior in age doing a video calling me a
wahab calling me a J look those words
don't mean nothing to
me genuinely I've been called far worse
far far worse I've been accused with far
worse the point is this though why are
you I don't want to use the word obsess
but why is there
this this pattern of trying to call us
out we are proud We follow I's view it's
as simple as that you have your
Viewpoint let's agree to disagree
especially when the situation is so dire
when people are being massacred and kids
have being blown into pieces why did you
find the need to come out once again
first it was the wedding and these are
the ones that we know of then it was
Muhammad on stage then you come to me
then you come for me I'm just saying
please for the sake of Allah subhana wa
tala you had your debate with ABD Hassan
you saw it people can watch it and make
the decision for their self we are not
going to go into that because I'm not
going to make this video where I don't
want you to look genuinely I don't want
you to get triggered and make a response
it's up to you all I'm just saying is
can we please come together on this
issue that is pertaining to our brothers
and sisters and end this
back and forth and there is not a back
and forth anyways but what I'm saying is
please for the sake of Allah subhana
tala with what's going on with the um
inshah let's put an end to this please
stop doing videos you can do it let the
situation of our brother sisters a
ceasefire and we can stop the Bloodshed
inshallah then you want to do 50 videos
about me that's fine you can do it back
and forth that's that's fine but right
now is not the time that's all I want to
say I wanted to go into more details I
don't want to because I don't want this
to turn into to a debate Etc and like I
said before the minimum that I would say
out of what I wanted to say was and I
repeat it again I a and I follow T's
View and I am absolutely proud of it I
am proud of it and that's all I want to
say inshallah may Allah subh guide you
and guide myself and one thing Allah
says in the Quran for example why do you
say something that you do not do
now you talk about Unity Unity Unity but
you are the same person sadly causing
this Unity
yeah you come and talk about these
credal matters that will be discussed
for hours on end so you are calling for
Unity but your actions are showing this
Unity so we're seeing actions speak
louder than words so please if you want
to see Unity then enact it let's see it
in your actions not only just your words
so please I'm urging you once again not
the time not the place to have this
Unity now let's unite on something that
we all at least agree on which is that
Allah says if you save one Soul it says
you save the whole of humanity let's
come together for that cause for our
Palestinian brothers and sisters
inshallah and end this bickering onon
for
all that's all I'm going to say
inshallah let's focus in helping our
brothers and sisters inshallah and this
video brother and sisters is sponsored
by one what they're doing at the work
they're doing on the ground in Palestine
so please please let's use this energy
whichever background you're from Asar
Sunni salafi you want to name whatever
it is donate for the sake of
tala so that at least this video brings
us together for the Palestinian courts
than rather dividing us that's all I
wanted to say assalam alaykum